[Música]
y
pocos días después de que la mayoría de
comunidades autónomas iniciara el nuevo
curso escolar hemos visto que se han
reportado muy pocas incidencias
alrededor de un centenar por coronavirus
en relación a los más de 26.000 centros
educativos que se cuentan en todo el
país eso sí uno de los casos positivos
se ha detectado en la clase donde
estudia la princesa de asturias y
heredera al trono leonor de borbón lo
que ha desembocado en una discusión
sobre todo virtual sobre los privilegios
de la casa real en este sentido en
relación al confinamiento que puede
estar viviendo la princesa leonor sin
embargo dejando de lado esta situación
anecdótica lo que preocupa realmente la
comunidad educativa es disponer de los
recursos humanos y materiales
suficientes para hacer frente a una
vuelta segura a las aulas y por eso
mismo la comunidad educativa de
enseñanza universitaria del país vasco
que volvía a las aulas esta misma semana
lo ha hecho con una huelga para todo el
profesional de este ámbito que según los
sindicatos que la convocan está teniendo
un seguimiento de más del 60%
[Música]
en agosto comenzó la segunda mitad de
este complejo año escolar en argentina
por la pandemia de coke 19 varias
provincias tenían la intención de
retomar las clases presenciales y unas
pocas lo hicieron pero debieron dar
marcha atrás un ejemplo es la provincia
de san juan en el centro este del país
la primera de nacer lo hace
aproximadamente un mes pero al poco
tiempo de retomar las clases
presenciales por el incremento de casos
de kobe 19 decidieron volver a las
clases a distancia ahora lo intenta a
partir de este lunes la provincia de la
pampa en el centro del país que empezará
a dar clases presenciales para cerca de
13.000 alumnos una parte del total de su
alumnado lo irán abriendo en forma
progresiva y los alumnos irán solo por
menos de tres horas a las aulas habrá
que ver cómo progresa esta experiencia
de la pampa lo cierto es que la mayor
parte del país con excepción tal vez de
algunas zonas rurales siguen con clases
a distancia sobre todo
y la provincia de buenos aires- y otros
grandes centros urbanos que concentran
un gran porcentaje de la población y por
lo tanto de los estudiantes
[Música]
emotivo y caótico así ha sido este
inicio de año escolar para unos 5
millones de alumnos italianos después de
más de seis meses de una inédita
parálisis de las escuelas italianas
caótico porque muchas de estas escuelas
no cuentan con las infraestructuras con
los espacios necesarios para poder
garantizar el distanciamiento social el
protocolo sanitario prevé también que en
los niños de más de 6 años deben usar
obligatoriamente las mascarillas dentro
de los colegios cada mañana los padres
deben tomar la temperatura a sus hijos
en caso de contagio todo el entorno del
niño inclusive sus compañeros de clase y
sus profesores deberán hacerse el examen
de coronavirus esto es para detectar lo
más rápidamente posible eventuales
nuevos focos epidémicos claramente el
país entra en esta nueva fase dividido
entre esperanza e incertidumbre
[Música]